[Music]
nomadic empires were some of the most
fascinating entities in human history
originating from the steps of central
asia most lived in isolation unbothered
by neighbouring empires who saw their
lands as worthless this isolation
allowed many nomadic tribes to
specialize increasingly in nomadic life
and warfare competing with other tribes
in a continuous struggle that in a
survival of the fittest way resulted in
ever-proficient warrior tribes and once
every few centuries they ventured forth
from their steps to overrun and conquer
settled societies that were ill-prepared
to face them however as efficient and
near unbeatable as these nomadic peoples
were in their conquests a curious thing
about them was that once they settled in
the lands they had conquered the nomads
turned into what they had conquered the
magia tribes conquered pannonia and
turned into the hungarian kingdom the
slavic tribes conquered eastern europe
and turned into the slavic kingdoms the
seljuk turks conquered iran and became
the new iranian empire the ottoman turks
conquered anatolia and became the new
romans the chagatai turks conquered
india and became the indians the mongols
conquered iran and became the new
iranian empire and when the mongols
conquered china they became the new
chinese empire there is however one big
exception in this series of historic
conquests by nomadic peoples and their
consequence social restructuring
russia medieval russia was not that much
different from many other medieval
european states at the time a collection
of small duchies cities and dukedoms
with no centralized overarching
authority the most prominent among these
were the kievan rus and the novgorod
republic the kievan ruse was a princely
state with deep cultural and commercial
ties into europe mainly through the
byzantines the novgorod republic was a
city-state and an important part of the
hanseatic league of cities that
stretched across the baltic and north
sea
then
came the mongols
there's a tendency amongst modern
historians to paint the mongol empire a
positive light as an institution of
trade and tolerance which though is very
oversimplified and overlooks the fact
that the mongol empire was an extractive
institution the mongols were tribal
people who had no state or legal
structures that they transferred over to
the people they conquered their relation
with those they conquered was purely
predatory they wanted to extract wealth
and resources from them and those who
refused paid dearly the kievan rus was
one of these places that resisted kiev
was burnt to the ground and the
surrounding lands pillaged with much of
the population slaughtered medieval
accounts tell us of fields filled with
human remains for decades after the
siege with the burning of kiev a
substantial political and cultural
transformation of what we now know as
russia began the kievan rus with its
deep cultural and economic ties to the
byzantians had been the cultural
motherland and birthplace of russia the
place where russia is a european
cultural entity had been created all
that was left of it now was ash the
cultural and economic ties with the
byzantians were now broken this resulted
in the geopolitical shift of russia
culturally and politically in power to
the north east
the mongols enforced their economic
order upon the remaining russian
principality states and the centre of
russian political and economic power
consequently shifted to the landlocked
plains of smolensk rostov and chanikov
these places and the princes who ruled
them had been largely ignored backwaters
before the mongols now they're still at
the center of russia throughout the rest
of europe the institution of feudalism
had during this time started to be
increasingly challenged new political
and commercial institutions evolved in
european trade cities from antwerp to
hamburg to koenigsberg warsaw paris
lisbon london and venice merchants
barons and artists and guilds rewrote
the feudal social contract additionally
the black plague shook up the economic
framework of europe dramatically with a
third of europe's population killed
there were no longer enough peasants to
work the lands for lords landlords
consequently started competing for the
remaining peasants by offering them
payment for work previously peasants had
worked in exchange for a promise of
protection that now became increasingly
replaced by a wage-based labor system
but russia remained untouched by these
political and economic developments it
remained under mongol rule for 250 years
and went into an entirely different
direction the princes of central russia
were recruited by the mongols as tax
collectors the mongols outsourced the
process of extracting the rhesus they
wanted out of the russian peasantry to
the russian princes because that
aristocracy had a lot to lose if they
failed to appease their mongol overlords
and because the mongols had brought no
legal code of limited aristocratic power
the russian princes extracted that
wealth with increasing unopposed
ruthlessness and brutality while in
europe feudalism increasingly disbanded
an increasingly exploitative economic
framework was reinforced in russia
urbanization didn't take place as it did
in europe with the russian princes
invested in keeping as many peasants
working the lands as possible the
russian princes recruited armies of
cavalrymen who were paid not in money
but in land and the peasants on it
however because there was so much land
control of the land was not as important
as control of the people while in europe
peasants gained access to wages and left
for cities to escape feudal lords in
russia the peasants became deeper tied
into their land through strict rules
tying them to it depth patronage and
brutal punishments for attempting to
flee the black plague had the opposite
socio-economic outcome in russia
compared to europe while in europe lords
started competing for peasants by paying
them wages the russian princes used the
plague to tie lands into enormous
statues and fiefdoms under a smaller
number of lords creating an enormous
peasantry working the lands of an
extremely small aristocracy
when nomads conquered a settled people
they usually turned into who they
conquered but here in a weird twist the
conquered russians almost became mongols
they were unshackled from any and all
political accountability to their
peasantry and could rule like the
conquerors whom they served but because
the russian princes merely served the
mongols and were not mongols themselves
they didn't adopt the tribal customs and
nomadic lifestyle of them the power
structure of the russian princely states
daba became heavily centralized within
the power of a singular ruler figure of
a state the russian princes even adopted
the warfare tactics of their conquerors
rather than build stone castles as the
rest of europe did they built wooden
fortresses and recruited large cavalry
armies when they were invaded they burnt
the wooden castles down ransacked and
burnt the fields of their own land and
then harassed invaders from horseback
while those invaders were forced to
march through and suffer the vastness of
russia
the russians also missed out on a key
development in european political
development at the time where a move
away from decentralized feudalism into
centralized absolutist kingdoms took
place creating the first large and
powerful centralized european states
over the 250 years of mongol rule with
the shift from kiev and novgorod to
central russia an economic development
away from commerce and artisans to a
peasant economy the most powerful
russian princely state to emerge was the
duchy of moscow which would eventually
be the one to rise up in rebellion and
kick the mongols out to create a new
russian state centered around moscow but
with the mongols gone the newly
independent russia kept the
socio-economic and political structures
that had developed under mongol rule and
strengthened them absolutism is a system
of governments in which all political
power lies within one singular ruler
beginning in the 1500s many a european
monarchy embarked on efforts to
construct absolutist states most
famously france it is during this time
that the foundations of the modern
nation state were laid but the
absolutism project in general was rather
unsuccessful the french monarchs drove
the state into bankruptcy and ended up
selling government offices and thereby
state power to the highest bidders the
stuart dynasty attempts to build
absolutism in britain ended with their
expulsion throughout europe urban
populations lower gentry and merchants
had made the establishment of the
all-powerful state difficult but the
conditions found in russia allowed the
russian tsars to create a near perfect
absolutism there are three main factors
that led to this
first russian society of the mongol rule
consisted of a monarch the army the
monarch paid with land an aristocracy of
boyas and a peasantry a key difference
to other parts of europe was that the
army was not incorporated within the
aristocratic class the army had been
directly recruited by the moscowite
state and was dependent upon that state
for its status and pay the state and
thereby the monarch could use the army
without constraints by any aristocrats
even against those aristocrats
second russia didn't experience the
regionalized feudal social structures
that the rest of europe did in fact
there is debate among historians if
russia experienced medieval feudalism at
all medieval feudalism was a social
system in which a peasantry submitted to
a military lord and his castle in
exchange for protection in russia though
the regionalized structure of
aristocracy didn't exist there were no
castles offering protection in these
vast lands and military power lay with
the state the new muscovite state also
introduced the mesti nestor a system of
hierarchies amongst lesser nobles that
pitted them up against each other in
competition for the favor of the monarch
in europe the lower aristocracy had an
important role in the creation of
parliamentary structures by forming a
political bloc competing with the king
for concessions privileges rights and
powers
in russia all power remained with the
monarch and the aristocracy was set up
to compete with each other for the favor
of the monarch
third law developed differently in
russia to the rest of europe one of the
key factors in the development of law in
europe had been the catholic church it
established almost state-like structures
that competed with monarchs for
authority creating standards for
accountability that evolved into written
codes of law kings of europe could not
just do as they pleased to their
subjects or their aristocracy violating
the standards set by the catholic church
resulted in harsh condemnation and
punishment by the church medieval
feudalism was not a mere exploitative
social framework it was a religious
social order under which systems of
accountability were created by religion
that limited the power of the state the
russian church was derived from the
byzantines and the eastern orthodox
church was cesio papist meaning that the
head of the church was appointed by the
monarch the christian church as it came
to develop in russia was an institution
subservient to the state and continued
to be throughout history be it to kings
emperors communist party bosses or
today's oligarchs
the completion of the russian absolutist
state occurred in the late 1500s and the
tsar ivan the fourth he established a
military district with absolute powers
to himself called the oprishnina and
inflicted a decade-long reign of terror
upon the country ivan had asked the
aristocracy permission for this
undertaking and they had approved which
goes to show how little the russian
aristocracy could do or even wanted to
do to limit the power of the monarch
even though ivan's reign of terror would
come at an enormous cost to them of the
many aristocratic families of russia
only nine survived this reign of terror
this state structure of absolute
unrestricted power within the monarch
continued after ivan including with the
establishment of the new romanov dynasty
in 1613 and it is not difficult to see
it continuing throughout the history of
more than russia you can see the slavish
capitulation of the russian aristocracy
to ivan's reign of terror almost
reflected in the capitulation of the
soviet politburo to starlin's reign of
terror and you can browse through the
list of murdered russian journalists
yourself to see that in many ways russia
remains a country in which state power
puts the ruling man above the law and
removes them from any accountability to
the law or the wider citizenry a mistake
often made though is to assume that
these developments were unavoidable and
somehow part of some inner logic of
russian culture itself the city of
novgorod continued to prosper and was
never conquered by the mongols its
institutions developed to have more in
common with those of european
city-states it was the gateway for
european goods into russia and russian
goods into europe which made it
incredibly rich the prince of novgorod
may have commanded an army but he was
accountable to the vetera a parliament
of the city that all three men of the
city voted for and which picked a mayor
from the city aristocracy the vets and
the mayor had control over taxation laws
and foreign policy it even had the power
to remove the prince of novgorod from
power to replace him with another there
was a different russian political
development which evolved to have checks
and balances as well as state
accountability and rule of law but that
development ended when ivan iii
conquered novgorod had its leaders
executed and its merchants and
aristocrats deported to the deep plains
of central russia one can only imagine
what more than russia would look like if
the free city of novgorod had been its
founding structure instead of the zardom
of moscow the only other russian
representative body was the zemsky
zaboor a council of aristocrats that
gathered to do little more but approve
the line of succession to the throne and
the proof of the tsar's wars until peter
the great even took those powers away
from it meanwhile in the rest of europe
parliamentary assemblies which in some
cases were as old as the middle ages
started gaining more and more power from
monarchs establishing parliamentary
political institutions and traditions
throughout europe in russia there was no
parliamentary institution until the
establishment of the duma in 1906 which
had its powers taken from it by the tsar
again only a few years later
by the 1700s the russian state was far
more centralized than any of its
european counterparts but far more
underdeveloped in economy and
bureaucracy there were no regional
political structures tied in
accountability to a central state
instead rule of local provinces was
handed out by the tsar in so-called
carmelini which means feedings and the
name kind of gives away the predatory
nature of the political institution
itself local rulers had no
accountability to law either and no
restraints on how much they could
exploit the office for personal gain as
long as they managed to appease the
centralized government when you look
closer at the previously mentioned list
of murdered russian journalists you will
notice how most are regional reporters
in small towns who were investigating
the corruption of a local police
department or mayor what's more is that
this practice of regional corruption
remained in place despite being reformed
by peter the great who instituted a
standardized system of regionalized
government which recruited the
aristocracy as local servants to the
state a reason for this may be found in
that the new system rewarded successful
local governors with tax exemptions
thereby incentivizing the aristocracy to
squeeze the peasantry even harder in
service of the state and themselves a
legacy of peter the great's reforms was
that the tax burden of the state was
increasingly placed upon the russian
peasantry while the aristocracy were
increasingly exempt in modern russia you
will find an enormous contrast between
the wealth of the oligarchs and your
average russian pensioner whose pension
is barely enough to sustain him in many
ways it has been a common thread
throughout russian history since the
1700s that the burden of securing the
state and the ambitions of wealth of its
ruler have been dumped upon the russian
peasantry from the trenches to the
gulags to today's pension and social
security cuts an additional aspect of
peter the great's reforms were the
introduction of severe punishments for
serfs who left their lands but also for
regional rulers and aristocrats who
granted more freedoms to serve some
peasants and thereby incited competition
with other regional rulers this bound
the rulers of russia on a regional level
even closer together to cooperate in
their exploitative economic structure
and tied them deeper to the centralized
state everyone was now tied together in
this and nobody could take the risk of
stepping out of line centuries later
those communist party members who may
have disagreed with the communist
politburo on something found themselves
shot and today those oligarchs who step
out of line with the central government
find themselves dispossessed jailed or
murdered russian absolutism was founded
on an alliance between the central ruler
of the state and the rulers of the
various subdivisions of the state to
enrich themselves at the expense of
everyone else it is why russia never had
a bourgeoisie a small business
middlestand commercial trader class or
any resemblance of equality before the
law and public accountability as the
historian john delon described it the
russian government more than any other
was a government of men and not of laws
and that aspect of russian absolutism is
what makes it so unique to show why we
can compare russia to another absolutist
state china which also underwent a
century-long political development that
resulted in a powerful centralized state
institution with absolute power and a
lack of public accountability but you
will find a very big difference between
the two chinese absolutism was built on
a foundation of meritocracy in
competition with patrimonialism chinese
rulers continuously found themselves in
positions of having to abide by some
standards of accountability to state
bureaucracy china has just as russia
gone through periods of incredible abuse
of power from the empress wu to the
great leap forward to the cultural
revolution but all these periods
resulted in reshuffling and
restructuring of the political
leadership to not repeat mistakes
mao zedong had to step down from the
politburo after his great leap forward
caused the great chinese famine and only
regained political power through a
populist coup with the cultural
revolution and that populism was
something the chinese state consequently
cracked down upon after mao's death
just as in russia the state is absolute
in china if you wish to protest against
a decision by the state or change the
course of the state you have to go
through the institutions of the state
and just as in russia you will find
corruption and abuse of power in china
such as local governments that cover up
the selling of poisonous baby formula
but the difference in the political
structure becomes very clear when you
compare abuse of power and corruption in
china the further you go up in ranks of
government the less corrupt state
officials become as a result of the
meritocratic state structures in russia
the further you go up in the ranks of
government the more corrupt state
officials become as there are no systems
of accountability the only measure in
restraint is that you can't be corrupt
enough as a local russian politician to
start bothering and annoying your
superior politician which is why the
government becomes more corrupt the
higher the office of the state is the
russian state is a system of
progressively corrupting power
in the next video we will be comparing
china and india more specifically the
millennial long developments in politics
and society that created such different
and even opposing state structures
subscribe if you wish to see it and
don't forget to like this video and
leave a comment if you enjoyed it and to
share it around on social media ways in
which you can support this channel are
also listed in the description i hope to
see you all next time